foreign
[Applause]
government
planning to investigate uaps I said to
myself what's a UAP and then you read
the fine print and it's unidentified
aerial phenomenon and I said to myself
that kind of sounds like UFO but
regardless whether we're talking about
UFOs or uaps both of them refer to
stuff happening in the sky
and you don't know what it is
period
okay we can agree on that
because that's what the U stands for
unidentified if there's something in the
sky that you later identify it goes from
being a UFO to an ifo and identified
flying object and then you move on why
should the government be interested in
UFOs seems to me if something over our
head could possibly pose a threat to us
to our safety to our health our economy
who are you going to call call the
military the Air Force I'm not surprised
that there's military governmental level
military interest in trying to figure
out what is happening in the sky among
objects you can't otherwise identify no
problem with that allocate some portion
of the Pentagon budget to identifying
them
people have come to equate UFOs with
aliens which is a curious equation in
our brains because they go something
like this there are lights in the sky
doing something I've never seen anything
do before I can't explain it I don't
know what it is therefore it's a
visiting alien from another planet so
what we tend to do is explain away our
ignorance with aliens now that's just
intellectually lazy aliens can't have
done all of that it happens on many
levels the people who see the pyramids
and rather than credit the African
culture who created them because you
don't know how somebody did it thousands
of years ago you can't figure it out and
you're not giving them the intellectual
credit for having accomplished it so you
say aliens help them it's a common sort
of fallback position what I would say is
as a scientist
you learn to
embrace the unknown
you encounter something you don't know
what it is I want to find out more
and you don't assert that you know what
it is after you've just admitted you
don't know what it is
you don't know what it is let's perform
more experiments let's get better data
let's keep investigating it so
I don't have any problems
continuing to investigate stuff in the
sky
a huge 200 foot diameter balloon that's
two-thirds the width of a football field
it's a big ass balloon up at 60 70 000
feet well above the civil aviation
flying Zone which is basically sea level
up to about 40 45 000 feet well above
that so it wasn't in anybody's way but
we didn't put it up there who did it now
there are treaties that control who gets
to fly over your airspace you can't just
take a plane and fly over anybody's
country that you choose not legally at
least and so this is what made the space
race of 60 years ago so interesting
geopolitically interesting because the
satellites were not flying over your
airspace they weren't over your space
space and there was nothing governing
that and plus you can't maneuver
satellites to go around your National
borders it doesn't work like that the
the the the gravitational physics
doesn't allow that so you can have
satellites over people's countries yeah
and nothing anybody can say you can even
Park a satellite over someone's country
in a geostationary orbit they're called
they orbit so far away that the time it
takes them to complete one orbit around
the Earth equals the time it takes Earth
to make one rotation so it appears to
hover over the same location on Earth
you do that too we've been doing this
for 60 years ever since basically the
early 1960s so balloons are kind of a
budget way to try to get information
from the ground but you need permission
to do that otherwise you don't get shot
out of the sky which is exactly what
Navy or the Navy or Air Force jets did
to the big balloon that floated across
the United States took a tour from coast
to coast it was shot down by a fighter
jet with a missile which is a little odd
for me think we might have a better way
to take out a balloon ultimately really
just popping the balloon
you're popping it and
a missile feels like overkill for that
maybe we should develop a new kind of
weapon week Weaponry just for popping
balloons uh that would be interesting
and uh cheaper than surely whatever it
was they used to shoot it out of the sky
maybe we could have shot it down over
Alaska but you want to learn about it
okay
you see something you don't understand
you say enemy kill it kill it or say hmm
if I watch this
and let's say it is your enemy I'll see
what the enemy might be up to try to
gather as much information as you can so
that's that's scientifically sensible
but could it have been carrying a
payload that is dangerous possibly so
get more information definitely all good
and by the way about a thousand or so
weather balloons between 500 and a
thousand weather balloons are launched
every single day so there's stuff
floating in our atmosphere all the time
they pose a danger only when they're if
they're high they're not but if they're
lower that's a problem we try to monitor
that what's good about a weather balloon
it goes up and you can bring it back
down and it sends you back data but we
have satellites now so weather balloons
are not as critical as they once were
given how many satellites we have
monitoring the conditions on Earth so
uh what do we have now we have some
other floaties coming in you know I
don't see why the this will ever end
uh but it'd be nice if we had a good
military response to it ideally you find
a way to capture it without harming it
then if it's some interesting technology
you reverse engineer it or the like some
of these we couldn't figure out what it
was I think the military said we don't
know what they are we shot them down and
it's scattered over a forest or the
tundra or the Frozen in the winter we
gotta find out and people heard the
government doesn't know what it is
whether or not they do know they said
they don't know and there again it was
it must be aliens
if aliens had a spaceship that crossed
the Galaxy and came to Earth and all
they're going to do is put a few
balloons out in the atmosphere really
that's their highest Tech thing they've
got I kind of was hoping for a higher
Tech aliens we might encounter I think
it's important to resist the urge
that just because we don't haven't
figured out what it is yet that it must
be aliens from another planet Carl Sagan
laid it out Simply by saying
extraordinary claims requires
extraordinary evidence and that's that's
a pretty simple edict to follow and so
yeah I'm not worried we're getting
invaded by aliens if we were you
wouldn't need
Navy Pilots
or Congressional hearings to establish
this we've got six billion smartphones
in the world we can crowdsource any
possible Alien Invasion and those videos
would be viral overnight maybe not as
viral as cat videos but alien spacecraft
coming it'll be up there okay and then
we don't have to go to Congress to get
them to tell us whether this is actually
happening and that's what's up with that
Neil deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
foreign